warning this feature contains themes
that some viewers may find offensive if
you are affected by any of the content
in this video please contact literally
anyone but me
hey 42 here before I begin I'd like to
say that this video will be a bit
different to normal because it will
contain a lot of opinion but I feel so
passionately about this topic that it
needs to be addressed if you're used to
my usual style of fact-based videos and
you weren't comfortable of hearing
opinions that you may not agree with
then I kindly ask that you give this one
a Miss so if you've watched the news
read the papers or use any kind of
social media within the last few years
you will have noticed an unsavory trend
that has been increasing with
exponential virality everyone is getting
offended by everything whether you have
been witnessed to it or not there is an
ever-growing number of ultra politically
correct far-left militants that are
hell-bent on campaigning for a cause for
people whom they've never even met and
who never asked them to campaign for
them in the first place and no this
isn't about politics it's far more
serious than that this is about
maintaining our freedoms and rights as a
human race and no sadly I'm not
exaggerating if you're not quite sure
what the hell I'm going on about let me
tell you about a fairly recent case that
just goes to prove my point about how
deadly political correctness can be in
November 2009 a psychologist working in
the US Army Nidal Malik Hasan opened
fire on the other troops in the base
while shouting god is great in Arabic
thirteen people were killed it was soon
discovered that the Pentagon knew all
about her son's radical ideologies way
before this act of terrorism they were
aware of a whole bunch of emails he had
been sending to her radical Muslims even
his own colleagues at the army base had
expressed their discomfort about him to
others saying that he was quote-unquote
a ticking time bomb
so how on earth could the US government
and the senior army management simply
allow this horrific mass murder to take
place well because the powers that be
within the US Army were too afraid of
being accused of racially profiling
someone to take any action against him
and so because of the unyielding
pressure of political correctness in the
modern age thirteen people tragically
had to die the effects of the over
offended can be seen strongly in comedy
the 60s 70s and 80s were full of
original geniusly witty TV comedies that
have yet to be bettered such as Monty
Python Fawlty Towers Black Adder Yes
Minister and a handful of others which
I'm sure you all have fond memories of
but there are too many to name here but
each and every one of these shows delved
into the realm of what overly sensitive
people today might wrongly calls sexist
homophobic or racist one notable example
is what many people consider to be the
greatest thirty minutes of TV comedy
ever written and performed the Fawlty
Towers episode the Germans the whole 30
minutes is stuffed full of non-pc jokes
that wouldn't dare to be part of any
contemporary TV sitcom one particular
scene shows a resident of Fawlty Towers
major Gowen using racial slurs against
West Indians and Germans sadly due to
the increasingly sensitive nature of
some TV viewers today this scene is now
completely cooked by the BBC from the
episode whenever they air it on TV but
what most people fail to say of course
is that the writers John Cleese and
Connie boof by no means supporting such
racial slurs they are in fact doing the
opposite they are making a joke out of
the majors a completely fictional
character ignorant and prejudiced
towards other cultures and races and
that is just toad
fine because racism is wrong and we
should make fun of those who practice it
so how is it that I can so confidently
say that such TV moments were
categorically not racist well for one
simple reason it is comedy comedy should
have no bounds
when horrendous unthinkable things
happen such as war the Holocaust slavery
disease and oppression it is human
nature to want to make things better
unless of course you are the one causing
suffering and we can often make good of
anybod situation by simply having a
laugh during the War and the Great
Depression comedy sitcoms and talk shows
were broadcast on radio stations all day
long every day such shows would often
attract audiences of 30 million plus
listeners 30 million people wanted to
listen to comedy in the middle of a war
because when the chips are down and all
seems lost it's just small things that
really matter it might just be that
moment of laughter one gets from a
comedy sketch on the radio
it might trivialize the seemingly
insurmountable issues you are facing by
poking fun at them and so making them
seem just a little bit less horrible and
slightly more tolerable of course being
intentionally prejudiced towards a
specific group of people is a horrible
thing but when we are forced to conform
to extreme political correctness it only
strips away our freedom of speech and
our ability to express ourselves
today's stand-up comedians have fallen
victim to the ever-tightening PC noose
around their creative necks more so than
ever
comedians are having to censor their own
material making it less offensive and
more politically correct just to appease
what many journalists are calling the
snowflake generation certain British
comedians such as Ricky Gervais Jimmy
Carr and Frankie Boyle have been
reprimanded repeatedly by British
television regulators Ofcom after making
offensive jokes on television because
the regulator's have simply been forced
to do so after numerous complaints by
the over offended TV viewers who feel
that they are entitled to restrict a
comedians freedom of speech and even
more frightening Glee the issue is
intensified by the fact that the
snowflake generation are using social
media and mass such as Twitter to
publicly ridicule and beat down any
comedian who uses anti PC language in
their comedy and so many comedians are
too afraid to write the material that
they truly want to and they are scared
of what the public reaction may be if
their content isn't entirely
family-friendly and how drastically sad
is that
but the slightly ironic thing is that
the snowflake crowd are in many ways
doing the complete opposite of what they
seek to achieve instead of censoring
offensive comedy some comedians are now
purposely being as offensive as possible
with their material in a backlash to the
easily offended populace as a way to
fight back against liberal oppression
and say that it's okay to be a little
offensive from time to time because we
are humans we are not perfect and
sometimes joining in on a joke even if
it's at one's own expense can be a most
joyous thing but sadly there is also a
dark side to comedians pushing their
offensive humor as far as it can go
because it tends to skew more towards
simple-minded toilet humor slapstick and
an overwhelming amount of forced bad
language and sex jokes this all takes
the place of what previously could have
been well thought out witty humor that
uses offence as a natural and organic
part of the joke instead of being for
into the material in an unnatural
belligerent and obviously artificial
fashion alas sadly no matter how hard
comedians attempt to fight back against
the snowflakes the reality is that this
crowd does wield power because of
advertisers today so many people are so
quick to lodge complaints against
television broadcasters and other
companies that TV executives are now too
afraid to invest money into original
writing talent just because it may be
too edgy or offensive for certain
demographics of their viewership and the
problem has made even worse as TV
broadcasters are held at the mercy of
their advertisers today advertisers
recognized the power of the snowflake
crowd and their ability to rant and rave
on social media about their brand if
they are seen as being slightly
offensive or prejudiced and so
advertisers will point-blank refused to
advertise on shows that could be
construed as offensive by pretty much
anyone and if the advertising money
isn't there then a show will never be
broadcast or made no matter how good it
could be we've all seen this exact same
issue here on YouTube in recent years to
protect advertisers and their
all-important revenue streams YouTube
has introduced new measures to
aggressively censor any content creator
that produces slightly edgy content by
stripping away their advertising revenue
their bread and butter I make a lot of
videos about history and war is a
prominent and natural feature of our
history which should be openly talked
about so we can learn from our mistakes
not to mention it's really interesting
but any video that so much mentions the
word war has been entirely stripped of
advertisements at least in my case
because god forbid someone out there is
offended by a recount of accurate
historical event
but we can't blame YouTube or even the
advertisers for this mass censorship it
really isn't their fault they are just
responding to what the public wants to
protect their own revenue and any
business would do that
it is the easily offended the
complainers those that are quick to
reprimand people who seek to speak
freely and unimpeded that are the ones
truly responsible they are the rotten
core the true cause of what has to
inevitably be a rapid decline in
creativity what is it really that wrong
to be offended no of course it's not
everyone gets offended from time to time
it is natural it is human nature to take
a dislike to comments or actions that
causes upset the public have always
taken offense that's not new what is new
and what is the true problem today is
people's feeling of entitlement that
they believe is given to them by being
offended because many Millennials
especially in the West have grown up in
a time free of violent war free of
oppression and poverty they have never
known what it's like to not have
everything to not get what they want
this has instilled some people with a
feeling of gross entitlement a feeling
that then being offended actually means
something well let me tell you straight
being offended doesn't mean anything
it's a natural human response and it's
okay to be offended or even disgusted at
other people's actions but it absolutely
does not give you the right to control
how others behave and talk if someone
calls you stupid you rightly should be
offended but that doesn't mean you can
start a campaign to prevent people from
using the word stupid that would be
stupid and it's also a little something
we like to call oppression don't get me
wrong I'm not talking about every
person out there far from it I'm simply
talking about a small small minority but
as is often the case in life it's the
few that spoil it for the many but why
is being so openly offended in making
sure that everyone possible knows how
utterly offended you are such a bad
thing
well there is a fundamental problem with
being offended and making a big deal of
it
offense is subjective what each of us is
offended by is vastly different from
person to person what offends us depends
on our social and economic background
our religious views or lack of the
friendships you've had how you were
brought up where you live your political
affiliation
you have Nissa t sexuality age gender
even your diet and just because you are
offended by a specific thing it does not
mean that the rest of the world should
be because we are all unique and varied
and if we weren't then wouldn't we all
be exactly the same and have the same
beliefs and that doesn't sound like much
fun does it my point is where does it
stop I'm slightly offended by people who
drink instant coffee but am I going to
protest against it or call the police no
because me being offended doesn't matter
it gives me no rights and it's not my
place to tell others how to behave at
the end of the day no one is being
harmed no crime has been committed so
why should I care everyone out there is
offended by different things you can
guarantee that no matter what you think
of there will be someone out there in
the world who finds it offensive you can
never fully police every thought freedom
of speech and people's behaviors because
doing so would be trying to police
everyone and everything that they say
the so-called snowflake generation are
trying to police thought and free speech
and the totally ironic thing is that the
vast majority of the millennial mind
police would consider themselves to be
very liberal wouldn't you say no I don't
know about you but I would say that
attempting to prevent people from
thinking a certain way from saying what
they want and stopping them from
behaving in a natural and human way is
the opposite of liberal it's actually
incredibly fascist and to make matters
worse it's not just a public that's are
getting offended too easily it's our
government too as was demonstrated with
a very recent and shocking case in
Scotland Scottish comedian and youtuber
Marc Meacham posted a video on YouTube
in which he lightheartedly explained
that he is sick of his girlfriend
thinking that absolutely everything her
pet pub does is adorable and cute and so
he thought it would be funny to teach
the pub to do the least cute and most
horrific thing that he could think of
which is of course being a Nazi so Marc
taught the pub behind his girlfriend's
back that upon hearing the commands
gasps the Jews the Pope would raise his
stubby little leg in what we would infer
to be a Nazi salute now of course the
hilarious thing about this is that the
adorable little pug has no idea what it
is doing it is completely dead path and
that's juxtaposition between the cute
and the horrific makes for a really
funny video is Mark me chin supporting
the views ideologies and actions of the
Nazis no does making and posting this
video online make him a neo-nazi or
supporter of anti-semitism absolutely
not because it was obviously intended as
comedy and no more than that and they're
categorically should be no rules when it
comes to comedy sure some people may
find this video insensitive but I'm
sorry you either have to have free
speech or nothing at all especially when
it comes to comedy because as soon as
you start to draw lines between what
okay to make fun of and what isn't you
start policing people's forts and
people's free speech and that is just a
slippery slope into a war on
intelligence and rational thoughts two
things that we must fight to defend no
matter the cost
after being posted on reddit meetin's
video went viral gathering 3 million
views subsequently Meacham was arrested
on suspicion of hate crime in March 2018
he faced trial in court in what was a
very sad day for freedom of speech
Meacham was found guilty and sentenced
to a fine of 800 pounds 800 pounds may
not seem like a heavy sentence but the
very fact that there was a trial at all
and even worse that a guilty verdict was
reached is a very sad precedent for
democracy free speech and everything
that makes being a human being free and
being able to express ourselves so great
and so precious in the words of mark
meetin himself when he start jailing
comedians for making jokes you're
heading down a slippery slope and my god
he couldn't be more right I'm not being
overly dramatic when I say that this
decision sets a very dangerous precedent
that should make us all very worried
about the future a free speech the judge
actually tried to put forward the
ridiculously absurd case that me trans
video was not intended as comedy but was
instead some kind of Nazi propaganda
with a goal to unite the masses in the
act of gassing Jews and the cute Pope
was only a way to disguise his true evil
and malicious intent I'm not pulling
your leg that is what the court
genuinely said this is obviously a load
of crap because it was unquestionably
comedy but one has to ask by sentencing
Meacham for making this comedy video
aren't the court suppressing his free
speech just like the Nazis did didn't we
fight against the Nazis to preserve
ability to speak and act freely and
avoid totalitarian oppression so it begs
the question who is really exercising
Nazi ideals here the only thing that was
refreshingly nice to see was the
overwhelming public support for mark
Meacham in defense of his ill-treatment
by the court many comedians also spoke
out publicly defending meetin's actions
namely ricky gervais providing hope that
rational thought and the desire for free
speech are still well under live within
our society let's just hope we can keep
it that way so to finish up I implore
you
the next time that someone gets offended
and complains at you for sitting the
wrong way in public for eating meat for
using gender pronouns for openly
supporting your favorite political party
for casually flirting with a stranger
for innocently touching another human
being for praying for your chosen Daisy
for earning more money than your peers
for making a simple joke or simply
because you don't identify as a
non-conforming gender fluid pansexual
cabbage do not stand for it
not for a moment because at the end of
the day you are only being yourself and
believe me there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that if simply being yourself
and doing what you know and what comes
natural to you offends someone else then
it's their problem to deal with it
don't let them make it yours or anybody
else's thanks for watching
if miraculously you enjoyed this video
then please click here to support me on
patreon don't forget to subscribe if you
haven't already